这条视频告诉你到底该怎么做短视频
怎么从领导意怎么订阅
怎么去购建自己的股价资亿的創作空价
然后怎么熬过那个点武器
然后怎么从领导师怎么去爆发
购建自己的商业模式
还是老习惯啊 想到哪儿说到哪儿
首先第一个
就是你在做短视频之前
你最好想一想
当然你可以上一个开始
但是你最好想的想你到底来干吗
就是你做短视频的目的是什么 这个要想
我不说你想的清楚
但是脑子必须有一个概念
比如说我刚来短视频的时候
我认识一个朋友
他会不会看到我的短视频啊
他叫王劳六
如果没有计则的话是王劳六
刚刚是他应该是八百万分析
然后每条的部分量是很高
是个搞消的博助
可能有人有印象
然后我刚来的时候我们还有还联系过
我当时我记得是十几万分析
他是八百万分析
后来不做了
并不了心
不做了
到底干嘛下去都我不知道
反正他过了
后来我发过一个消息
他说他不做了
所以可以看
在这样的朋友我还认识两个
就基本上是有两个大
但是
并不了心因为他来生活都是问题
所以你来短视频之前
你要想你到底通过短视频
干吗
你是增加影响利益
对吧
我不是想通过他怎么样
我们也不卖货也不卖货
对吧
我是增加影响利益
然后用他别的地方
比如我的企业
对
像的英老师一样
对吧
所以你来之前脑子
要有看见
比如说
我是做影响利益
对吧
然后我还是写书
我还是做客药
还是专闹
那我还是卖货
对吧
我还是做网告
然后有了这个干净之后
你想
你面具的是哪些人群
你面对的是哪些人群
你的用户是他
这个很重要
不是你要想明白
但他很重要
我举个例子你就明白了
比如说你是卖欧威的
高端是品牌
然后我而且保了
是品牌
你很开心
对吧
但是
来的人都什么人
都是酒块酒包油的
你能提供
这个时候
他不对你不一定是好事
反而是早已
所以你要做第一步
不是马上想明白
但是你必须去想
一样说
我来的目的干吗
然后我的商业模式
怎么勾键的
我需要什么的用户
然后我是面对
这样的一群用户来创作
内容的
所以你每次从那种的时候
你的头脑装要有
他
你就是给他排的
而不是我
我按我
我要有两
那个东西都是书馆
这时候第一件事情
第二件事情的话
就是你刚上来的时候
就新手期
新手期
我要给你们破除两个垃圾
第一个垃圾是什么呢
就是
他不会推你的
就我举个例子
就是你虚愿是一个人
这个人你刚认识
然后来找你
说那个谁谁
胡子和你
帮我介绍个谁
帮你赶紧上吗
你赶紧上吗
你知道他靠谱吗
你赶紧上的
什么你靠谱
是不是说
因为你对这个人
根本不了解你
你怎么就介绍
因为你去介绍的
过程中
千万你赞
赞我调了吗
尤其是我
自己的事很厉害
对不对
人家就用过来我的平台
好啊
家我我挂啊
你介绍给他们
怎么可能呢
所以他没有办法介绍
他还不知道你是谁
他对你还没有
更多的认识
没有不要切儿了
你先向我
就现在就不要随意了
为什么不要随意呢
你对我以前有
不要切儿了吗
对吧
你干什么
没有不要切儿了
这是第一个事
但第二个事
行为要跟你解释
你是有新手保护期的
有新手保护期
就你刚开始的时候
他也怕错过人才
他也怕你讲的东西
是有好东西的
所以刚开始他不会
以上两个大标切儿了
你怎么说
我带有个骑士调
到底是骑士调我不知道
但是肯定是
我怎么骑士调
我让你那个
让你度过新手期的
但是我告诉你
这里被个大坑
我这两天看着了
就有那种不复子的人
你上来告诉你
你一天拍一百条
你真的一天拍一百条
你用不了两天
你就打上标切儿了
各位
除非你确实很牛
你上来就有一个
就有一个标切儿
错误啊
你会发现
你打了一个标切儿
啥呢
就是你拍的那种
你一天一百条
你只量不可以太高的
对了
然后你前几百条
估计就已经把你的标切儿打了
就第一次创造者
你再想发生
很难了
所以不要相信那种
一天拍一百条的那种
没有意义好不好
就是我之前
我之前说过
就是我拍一条视频是五分钟
就我现在小时候
一条视频是五分钟左右吧
对不对
我不需要准备
你能做的
好不好
就算你能做到
一条五分钟
一百条是五百分钟
一天九小是十二不干
你是打了一达
打 打 打 打 打 打
了那么坏 换另外一个吗
所以
那么这个时候
新手新脚干什么
我们叫叹珍奇
就是你利用这个新手
把无需
你找到死得定位
所以刚开始
你不要担心
你搬事
投几条没问题的
拍出来的时候
千万不要
最醜夹缓
我刚才说了
不要涉到夹缓
不要追求力不了
那个东西来了一群你也揭露
硬应对地球不穩互
所以这个时候
其实
最好的方法是什么呢?
就是
你每一条视频
你其实是有目的的
我这条视频是派的谁的
我的许覾体的是什么
我的结构是什么
然后我个人的这种
挺续续热热的表达是什么
我爬出去
出去以后要付牌
我们很觉得最大的问题
不会付牌
不付牌
我就敲他遇
在条曲串来就运那条串
我愿意出去以后要付牌
把它全联石来
我怎么不要是谁
来的是这些用户人去吗
有没有人在下面留言说
这就是我想要的东西呢
对对人们的留言评论到底是是是什么呢
对对
好了
就说我第二条出去
我是测开头了
测完开的
我就想
我就想提升我的版本罗里
完了以后我要看
我的版本罗里怎么样
所以前面那个
那个起似的版本的上
你做实验做实验的
那你一定要干什么各位
你一定要复盘记录
每条是本对复盘记录
你在这上面花的时间应该凭你
拍视频的花的时间还多
你就永远记住了
进步的一个什么
进步等于犯错加反思
你要是没这种你别别折啊
我从还在课曹一些
一天拍一百条这个
神经病
就是我把话放在这
你不要看那帮人说
一天拍一百条读读病
有一个算一个全罗
每一个屁我读病的
就是他以前拍一百条了
不服对吧
谁赞成谁反对
对三个
我们说到人性
什么是人性呢
人性是这样的
每人就喜欢
就是人天生就喜欢
确定性就喜欢把我的东西
所以他老是面对
不够种不确定
他会慌的
所以如果你看在这流量不好的话
你自己会慌着他也正常的
但是我告诉你
你尤其早期
你磨错为止了
我刚才来的时候以后
就是虽然平台比你们好
但以后
不要不要靠意识
我告诉你
这个时候你毛病的点
不是有多少播放量
不是的
你这个时候毛病点是什么
是
我今天掌握了一个开头的机枪
我今天终于理解了
企业高是什么能力
对吧
就是我进步在什么地方
我掌握着整个结构的什么部分
所以你要做的事情是在
探测期一定是
把你的结构里出来
一定要有个东西
所以记得了吗
每台一条是给一定有个复盘
选题用户
我要测什么
结构是什么
我的素材或者什么
哪个东西可以复用
这什么时候的
我们是我们讲的第二个部分
然后我们讲第三个部分
就是当你去
第三个部分其实是我们过去
我觉得我希望你做东西
一定要有系统
我还是认识的话可能会此痛
你他不完全准确
但是大概一分你也就好了
因为我排东西不准对了
凶人赚钱
考立起
考时间
考经历
副人赚钱
考系统
就拿我来说各位
我们做个对比就好了
我现在我基本上都知道
如果你是个新手的话
你每天有花好伤
是可以拍个这边的
好伤之间就准备的
然后拍的拍的就没领导了
是不是
但是我告诉你
我每天拍什么
你看我现在这样
你们都知道我是不准备的
对吧
所以我拿过来我用的拍
原因是什么
原因是我有素材
我每天按照的领导
我今天还在我们
在我们说明给大家
想认识
你看我的领导是什么
每天认识
认识领导
有了领导
它就可以拍为什么
因为我是有结构的
主持人一丢短什么
到底是什么样的结构
开头中间的结构
虽然你看我不准备
但是它这有结构的
有的结构就不会太差
而且本身上来说
我才做自己的事
明明看
我是做自己的事
我什么短视频
什么文章
取完了我是副产品
我只要让自己变好
我是我比较好了
对我的
对我的人生就在那儿了
那门人们会因为你
在世界观
然后你的生活经历喜欢
你而不是你的表演
对吧
所以我就是有自己的事
然后每次拍的短片
那时候你拿过来
就可以拍
那是因为我有系统了
什么系统
就是我那个
我跟大家在看一些我之前
每天写点什么
写什么
不是让你写
写乱七八刀写
写什么
我今天哪些事做的是好的
这个事一定要把它做的更好
每些事做的是不好的
以后就不要做的
然后
共同女的那个系统
我断的让你那个系统
越早期愿意那个系统
然后你越享受这个系统的复理
它就会形成一个所有人
所以赚到点钱以后
别胡话
赚到点钱以后
购不见自己的购买资产
资产人什么
资产不一定是买什么
公司医学是投资
资产可以
是你自己运行的系统
我跟大家讲
我现在整个系统
全是全是成品自己跑的
就是我每天根本不用
不用去管他
他就已经可以跑了
这是不一点一点大建筑的
记住
再要好的系统
都是从最简单的东西
大建筑的
今天大块算明天大一个转
永远不要整个重成点
复职一个复杂的信用过来
你把我不住
听听说的汗
好吧
这点这么多吧
我简单做个总结
好好思考一下
第一
做之前首先想想
你的商业模式什么
你能不能不要是什么
你为你的用户
人群是谁
然后你能给他提供什么
刚才是不用强的那么庆祖
但你大概有这么一个概念
千万不要出现那种情况
就是你是买了我位子
然后来了一帮
对吧
就会有朋友的
你看我现在拍的视频
我不知道怎么怎么能把这个
流量做更好帮我告诉你
我太清楚了
但是你看我现在拍的视频
都是这种
就是想想来就聊
而且你会发现有些时候
我故意从家难度
阿里说我准备准备就要
是否就会帮我的
对不对
但是我不准备为什么
因为我要面对的人群
不是那种
你来为我
你倒是动一些
我的这个下方
我不让这种人
我看这种人反应
你知道吗
我要的就是那种
愿意动脑子
阻动学习的
认
这些人才是
我希望
我们再一块
未来的路上再一块
前行的人
对吧
那我就故意说
这样的事情
对不对
人少一点
LW门口人多吗
不多呀
是不是
所以
这是第一个
就是你要做什么的
伤害吗
什么面对是
第二个是行
就是
新手探测期期视条
我到底多少条
我不知道
一个人是保密的
对吧
几个条或者一百条
记住
不要随着拍
每一百
但是
它只有保护梯
但是每拍一条
你都要用
不要性的
我这次是测选题
我这次是测我的
我的各种的形象
我的
我的这种
就是形象的东西
我表达
我的这一条
我是测我的
选题
这条是测标题
这条是测
结果
每次都完了以后
一定要付款
你必须无效怪本
没有付款
你的视频作不出来
你们们是有没有付款
没付款
你不配
这时候我们讲的第二句是
你要通过它
勾结系统的第三句是
就是勾结系统
你只有勾结系统了以后
你的流量才是闻闻的
你才敢像我
这样
随着拍
你能理解吧
然后你为外面
你这个时候你就可以
因为它是系统的
它能理解的
原谅不断的收益
然后你拿出一部分来打造一套系统
你就可以花很多时间
你不用把时间放在这儿了
你会花很多时间
去做自己喜欢审常切
复理点事
把你自己游然而然
就是你吃不完怎么办
你实际上带着那种气质
就是人民喜欢的气质